he reached an empty space
with confusion on his empty face
roll it gladys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is amazing music that was terrible
that was biden wrapping up a speech in
north carolina yesterday shaking hands
with thin air
after babbling about ghost guns now he's
reaching for ghost hands
good thing it wasn't a high five he
would have flung himself off the stage
but you know that joe's been on a lot of
university campuses
i've been on a lot of university
campuses matter of fact for four years i
was a full professor at the university
of pennsylvania
well that's news to us and to him too
since it isn't true
he's got a million he got a million
dollars and didn't teach any classes so
hunter definitely learned from the best
so while he stands on stage and putters
his popularity in the gutter new poll
gives him a 33 approval rating among all
americans to the lowest yet and it's no
better among younger generations
among gen z biden's seen a 21 point drop
in support among millennials 19 percent
drop but he still scores well in the key
democratic voting block of dead people
meanwhile where's kamala probably
acknowledging that one must acknowledge
prices are going up
i acknowledge one must acknowledge
the prices are going up
she's the best
glad she acknowledged that one must
acknowledge it she could be a professor
of a class on lowering expectations
finally shinsaki wasted no time
thrashing fox news on some podcast
podcast last night
so we have to talk about peter ducey for
one second sure
is he
a stupid son of a [ __ ]
or
does he play a stupid [ __ ] on tv he
works for a network
okay that
provides people with questions
that nothing personal to any individual
including peter ducey but might make
anyone sound like a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
speaking of she'll do great on msnbc
joy reid needs one friend
joe what say you
no no no no look look
young people love me all right
and gen z
with the redhead she's my biggest fan
and you got it wrong i wasn't
shaking hands i i was working on my i
like what young people are doing i'm
working on my latest tick tock video
so i had the moves did it
don't don't
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't
don't don't hand jive come on man
oh my goodness cat is peter ducey a
stupid son of a [ __ ] yes or no
no oh good i just i just think it's
funny that like she thinks that like we
are all told what to say yeah i know
which would be really disturbing on my
part particularly yes
who the hell is writing for me yeah
so you're going to tell this story this
happened to you
yes uh kat this is uh this is uh the man
can you tell the story about the time
you let that guy
stay in your apartment yeah you're
pushing straight forward oh yeah exactly
yeah could you just say you took in a
stray human yes
uh yeah
no i came i came up with that all on my
own
decisions and everything
but i think it's maybe because she's
working in an administration where so
much of it involves telling joe what to
say right he can only say what he's told
to say and when he ever says something
he's not told to say they have to it's
really tough for her to have to spend so
much time walking it back so maybe
that's why she thought that yeah i think
she also thought she was being funny and
like kind of a badass
you got to try hard to be a badass
you're not one yeah so true
so true tyrus what do you make of uh the
biden latest uh
the handshake was tough
yeah it was bad it's like watching your
favorite boxer who can't fight anymore
you know and he's in the corner just
getting yeah stabbed up and everyone's
telling him to go down but yeah legs are
like no we're still in it and then our
evil producers put music to it yeah that
was that terrible jean guy yeah he's
just keeping an eye on him you know it's
terrible yeah he's he just ruins our
skit
i heard your directions clearly i said a
respectful
yeah he did it his way but yes you know
when you real quick i just find that
when you if you're going to call
somebody a stupid son of a [ __ ] you got
to be smooth about it and i've never met
an administration from top to bottom
that is so unprepared and horrible
speakers if you are still using the word
um when you talk maybe you shouldn't
talk yeah you know like nothing kills a
speech more than um so i was going to
the store um and then i actually am kind
of digging the new vp
say it twice it sounds nice because i
acknowledge the fact that one has to
acknowledge because and again what is
acknowledgement i'm acknowledging to
acknowledge your acknowledgement
somebody who's really high yes that's
like that one guy who has great ideas
right when he's high and they're really
bad ideas but he's got to get it out and
also he's when the guy's really high but
the person he's talking to isn't exactly
and you have to like try to figure out
if you're if you're if they know you're
high that's kamala all the time kennedy
she i and it's like and we're discussing
the passage of time
my favorite thing if you're ever in a
bad mood just watch videos of kamala
harris describing inflation
because you will get the chuckles like
she did in that lester holt interview
right she she is so bad at that stuff
and who the hell is jenn sake that
unethical propagandist
she is pointing fingers at peter ducey
whom i'm told she is secretly obsessed
with and who can blame her because he is
one juicy ducey
his questions are respectful they are
thoughtful and he writes them you can
tell because he asks follow-ups that she
also propagandizes and doesn't answer so
shame on her
and uh i believe that that he has a
legal case especially you know it's like
oh here she is negotiating a deal with a
news network right to go opine when
she's still propagandizing from the
white house podium during record
inflation and a potential world war
right so so she is you know
a page from the biden playbook take
whatever you can take advantage of it
you know some sly moves and some
sleaziness and
knit yourself a career
what do you think julie i mean i don't
i'm a son of a [ __ ] but definitely
peter ducey is not that he that was
basically a call back to didn't biden's
call
yeah yeah yes absolutely but first of
all he's been a thorn in their side
since the the campaign right because
they don't like his questions i mean
it's obvious he's the only one in the
room he's not like acosta no
oh my god exactly acosta was all about
making the story about himself right and
it's interesting that nobody was they
weren't calling acosta any names because
he was obviously propping them up so
during the campaign he was asking biden
the questions and they were biden was
rude to him on the campaign gensake is
now continuing and then she's going to
go to msnbc and i'm sure bash fox which
will only help our ratings yeah i don't
know how she can still do this uh job i
mean
isn't there supposed to be a separation
i don't understand that it's so
unethical
i just believe that the you know
correspondents association they are
definitely they should they should say
something yeah i mean how if if if under
trump the press secretary said that
about one of our reporters or not about
one of our reporters but about costa or
anybody at cnn or ms i mean they'd be
they'd be a threat to our democracy yeah
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else